oh dude i might need your help okay
you might have to bring your guns over
okay because guess what we caught on the
camera last night at 3 a.m so i have my
uh
rings like i have a security system with
cameras that's in the house that ring
too and the ring picked up some movement
3am so my phone goes off and i look the
old line of the mountain oh
mountain lion
and listen is that true that's true i'll
show you the video and how disrespectful
is this he took
the biggest [ __ ] on my lawn wow just
have to [ __ ]
a mountain lion
that's crazy not a big one because you
live in a fairly
are you sure it wasn't a bobcat short
tail or a long tail long tail i'll show
you not again not not a big one though
but took a probably took a mufasa size
[ __ ] on my lawn really yeah
insulting if you ask me i was going to
say but a little different that's crazy
you had a mountain lion in your home
rare you can't leave your dogs out you
can't leave certain dogs
my kids really out there but he's i
didn't come at you at night well yeah i
know my kids aren't partying to three in
the morning did you still like i had
some people what are you talking about
about hilda my my my late yeah oh no
murder no it's me yeah so my my girl
hilda who was murdered uh my my turtle
uh was murdered by a raccoon and the guy
said a guy said
your your this raccoon won't stop
until
everything is dead oh it's the night
stalker of raccoons yeah damn it kills
my koi it's [ __ ] on and i'm thinking
he's saying that quick so he probably
won't get him they can corner him though
those [ __ ] raccoons oh raccoon grab
they'll grab some fish hey but also the
people that you mailed to you know what
you're talking about well no this guy
they do pond they do ponds yeah they say
we'll come out yeah sure put a net over
your pond yeah i was like is there
anything lamborghini
what's the point of the pond
so then it takes away the beauty of the
other hey also [ __ ] those koi fish let's
roll the dice there well i might say
we'll try and get more koi fish i'm
going to get another trailer i'll set it
to try to stab all night [ __ ] shoot
him in his website no no no here's what
i'm going to do i'm going to set it set
the trap okay that one will be in
anything and then i'll go like this i'll
look at him and he'll be like
i'll look him in the eye and i'll say
you live or you do not live as it
pleases me
as it pleases me
and then i'll just then beat him with a
bag of soap yeah like full metal jack
because it's just like cake
dude we'll just hide in the bushes till
this [ __ ] robber shows up i promise
those [ __ ] who probably can smell us
and they know
they roll like we cover garbage
high descent that's a good idea
that's a good idea all right cover your
face and poo right i'm gonna roll don't
they roll as a group i'm gonna scat baby
in the face just to catch the raccoon so
i got poop why do i have to be the one
covered in poo it's your raccoon i know
but what are you doing [ __ ] on you
okay but then i feel like human [ __ ] on
my face do you want to cast a raccoon or
not i i guess this is my plan this is
ocean's 11 i'm george clooney yeah
you're brad pitt so do i have to get
under you while you cop a squad oh god
this is so [ __ ] i feel like this
you're getting off this give me a log
like a trojan i'm sure this is good for
catching raccoons dude the best so i'm
all shit-faced no pun intended
and you're hiding
and then we come out i like that just
covering [ __ ] yeah
can i get in the shower now no no sir
waiting for this raccoon i gotta get
serious yeah i wonder if it is a raccoon
though i bet it is i read this it's the
only thing i can think of i tell you
what though your life is better than
mine man i have [ __ ] a mountain lion
of the mountains that's no joke tiny
little dude though not huge yeah